quelle est la dernière chose dont tu te
souviens
dany nous satisfaire si tu as survécu
c'est parce que tu n'es pas une jeune
fille ordinaire tu n'es plus seul
plus maintenant savez vous ce qu'est un
mutant l'un d'eux vous souhaite raconter
sa première fois rain
j'avais 13 ans c'était comme dans un
rêve
je maîtrisais plus rien sam
j'en sais rien j'ai paniqué il ya eu des
blessés
robert temps c'est ma copine je les
brûlés vifs
il y en a j'ai tué 18 personnes une par
une
[Musique]
on n'est pas dans un hôpital on est en
cash
[Musique]
il est capital d'identifier ton pouvoir
si on veut aider à guérir
j'ai des quelque chose
un truc qu'elle voulait pas que je vois
[Musique]
je crois pas qu'on soit là pour guérir
cet endroit fait ressurgir des plus
grandes peurs il te les faire vivre
jusqu'à ce qu'elle te tue qui et c'est
là
on peut s en sortir ensemble
[Musique]